you wanted the devil
well you got him the devil is in the
details and that doesn't ring more true
than for the effects in lucifer with six
seasons packed full of beautiful visuals
the vfx team had their hands full
creating this epic story the behind the
scenes will make you wonder how they
took something that looks so boring and
bare and turned it into the epic scenes
we see on screen they must have made a
deal with the devil to make the effects
look this good on such a tight schedule
and budget oh yeah
watch this
as the king of hell lucifer isn't your
ordinary fallen angel while he may
appear to be a handsome bachelor on the
outside on the inside lucifer hides a
devilish look we don't see it often but
every now and again we get a look at
lucifer's true complexion known to fans
as his devil face the first time we see
this is in the pilot episode of the
series we only get a glimpse for a few
seconds but it's enough to make out the
look
this is actually the only time the
effects department used makeup and
prosthetics to accomplish the look as
future iterations would be achieved with
cgi and there were multiple iterations
along the way season 1 and season 2 had
a smoother design with some folds and
cuts season 3 is where the look reached
its most well-known form with only
slight changes being made in the
following seasons actor tom ellis had
tracking dots painted on his face to
assist the vfx team in post-production
bridge what's going on here
the effects reference that was for when
we only saw the face but season 4
introduced us to lucifer's full devil
body including wings for this ellis wore
a full motion capture tracking suit
including a cap and of course the motion
dots on his face again we can say it was
worth it though as his devil appearance
looks incredible
one aspect of lucifer that's impossible
to miss are his giant wings they are cut
off in the first season but return in
the season two finale they were actually
brought back after amena deal lost his
wings strictly because the budget could
not sustain them we had him but we don't
think we can sustain the level
production and make these wings work the
creators decided they would rather
lucifer have wings and so amena deal
lost his although the writers did a
great job of making it part of his
character arc the wings were completely
cgi and took a lot of time to render but
they didn't require as much onset help
as you might think tom ellis didn't have
to wear any special tracking suit for
the wings in fact he wore his normal
suits and green tracking markers were
taped to the back simple right this
actually turned out to be a huge
headache for the crew the tape didn't
actually adhere all too well to the nice
suits and kept falling off this is a
bigger problem than one might think the
tape has to be put back on in the exact
same spot or else the vfx shot will be
imperfect let's look at a scene where
lucifer uses his wings in this scene
where lucifer is having a dream where
chloe is falling tom ellis is actually
on a green screen and the environment is
computer generated and in the season 3
finale when lucifer makes a grand
entrance to get revenge on kane
everything is cgi including lucifer
himself the scene transitions into a
live-action fight scene while keeping
the cg wings and it does so flawlessly
the devil has his ways of tricking us
the first wings we did
were supposed to be the last wings of
the show the process of creating the
angel wings for lucifer was anything but
straightforward to begin with they
weren't even sure if they were going to
be sustainable on their budget it's a
common thing that for budgetary reasons
not because of narrative reasons
someone's written or some aspect of a
show right now once they knew they were
going to be bringing back the wings
regularly they created big beautiful
feathers that had their own custom rake
for the vfx team to animate with there
were multiple elements to manipulate the
wing rig which controlled how the
overall wings moved and reacted and the
individual feathers which could be
transformed in multiple different ways
and some of the feathers they created
for lucifer were really big the ones on
the end of his wings are like as big as
his leg with so many detailed feathers
and animation rendering a single frame
took five to six hours he was like okay
yeah this is gonna work another giant
headache for the vfx department was the
scene in the season 3 finale where
lucifer shields and protects chloe with
his wings they had to create an entirely
new pipeline to create this scene and
just figuring out how to do it took them
a full month some new challenges they
faced included getting the feathers to
bend correctly and making them bleed
that's not the only unique aspect of our
favorite fallen angel just like the
wings lucifer's devil face also had to
undergo changes as the seasons
progressed a couple of the main things
the vfx team focused on tweaking were
his eyes and making his overall look
less smooth we just kind of take divots
out of him and make more gouges they did
all this work for the big reveal at the
end of the season 3 finale only for the
show to be cancelled right after luckily
it was brought back on netflix so we
could see more devil face and wings than
ever as netflix's budget allowed for
more vfx shots this included bringing
back the updated devil face this time
with a devil body and wings to go along
with it but the wings and face aren't
the only things that make lucifer
lucifer he is the ruler of hell after
all and can't be spending all of his
time on earth one of the most impressive
shots of the series comes at the end of
the season 4 finale when lucifer returns
to hell he presides over his kingdom
sitting high above the land in a giant
chair to create this scene they shot tom
ellis on a simplified version of the
chair on a raised stage and a green
screen background the behind the scenes
definitely isn't quite as epic as the
final shot but it shows how drastically
vfx can change the look of a scene
while we've been taking a look at the
grand expensive and in your face vfx
shots there are some special effects
sprinkled throughout the show that you
may not have even noticed when kane is
impaled during his fight with amena deal
despite going through him isn't there at
all it was completely added in post and
when lucifer finds out that pierce is
actually kane and stabs him the knife
blade is cgi actor tom welling was
holding a handle and feigning the action
of pulling the blade out of his chest
that scene in season 3 where lucifer
intimidates a murder suspect by dangling
him off a cliff real car with green
screen on the ground and the cliff
created digitally and who can forget
that fantastic dance sequence in season
4 where lucifer pulls a dirty dancing
and lifts dan in the air this was done
practically with wires which were
removed in post the result was an oddly
perfect sequence of the devil showing
everyone his incredible moves but that's
not all there are some scenes you would
never guess contain visual effects
during a scene at a ballerina recital
the entire audience was added separately
and when the car explodes next to
lucifer and chloe they replaced the
stunt doubles face with actress laura
germans even though it's only on screen
for a second it's the small attention to
details like these that help keep the
audience engaged in the show with them
none the wiser of the amazing work done
by the vfx team it's impressive what
these vfx artists are able to accomplish
with such little time and money they
pour their hard work into these effects
and the results speak for themselves the
amount of work they do with the amount
of limitations they have is nothing
short of spectacular from angels to
devils the effects in lucifer have only
continued to improve throughout the
seasons which effect do you think was
most impressive